look
[Music]
hello how are you greetings to him and
jaramillo with his brief information today
Monday June 8, 2020 the
community shows support for what has been injured
during a blackwater protest they
pay tribute to him in a parade named let's
pray for 66  a thousand colones of 29 years
was shot outside the
being that is last Monday he
is still hospitalized in
critical condition in Iván if after having a
successful surgery during this event
family members drove through the hospital
honking their horn in  a sign of
support
there is an account for injured officers
to help with donations and thus
be able to be part of the
recovery process of m colones you can donate
through wells fargo or nevada state
bank you can also go to the
punto vegas page for more details visit
illusion  dotcom
while the man accused of
shooting the officer and granted
a million dollar
bail édgar samaniego faces charges  he
attempted murder of an agent the
shooting occurred on Monday night
during a protest outside the
being who is samaniego was not a
protester his next hearing will be
on july 31
nevada legislators are working to
discuss the injustices within
law enforcement agencies
attorney general
grand bourg organized a virtual panel
to discuss the training and
hiring process for these
agencies one of the topics that was addressed
was providing body cameras to
all officers, especially
those units that  they have no
obligation to use it there was also talk of
creating a committee for a new
security control law and it will be supervised
by the prosecutor's office and now
we are going through with your forecast a
sunny day is expected with temperatures below
normal the maximum will be in the 80s  degrees
but we will continue to climb until we
reach 100 degrees on Thursday
I am this light mine and this was great
in Spanish
[Music]